hey guys i'm ryan right hey guys so
today's Sally and I are gonna check out
the video a tribute to Sally and Ryan of
the real rejects keep it up is what it
ends with by the dnw
alright let's see what it is Sally there
is a 15-second intro please read what it
says intro okay this test yeah I can't
talk this text last for 15 seconds of
pause if you need to hey Sally we know
you've had a bit of a rough time so I
decided to make this for you oh my god
let's cute I've been up for sixty hours
working on my own sizzle reel so it's
not the best done but I needed a break
from pinnacle and just use wmm to put
those together reporting tonight I hope
you enjoy this little tribute and I
promise to make a really nicely done one
once I'm doing our project so cute
forgot to mention they jerked off to you
before when Ryan I clicked on every ad
and watch them for both act about 40
minutes worth in addition to the Sally
videos I just powered through enjoy guys
oh this person is my new favorite person
in the whole entire world oh my gosh I
don't know how to accept this it's just
I feel like thank you that really does
make me feel good I like I want to
express love but I don't know how I
don't know how yeah I just say something
real fast
yeah what everyone's thinking Sally's
totally back and everyone's like where's
Sally thing like where what happened ah
what the [ __ ] for wanna go no Sally you
all right Oh like you're in the peak a
my laptop's are working I can't play
music I love you Sally
[Music]
ah oh my god [ __ ] will smiling soon if
you're out there sings I thought that it
was beautiful you looked absolutely
beautiful your voice is beautiful a
dress really brought out your stuff go
get it for me oh yeah bra blood salt
this is just a bird yeah ow
oh that's cold Sally mm-hmm a lot better
with hair yeah let me clean [ __ ] cheese
to shoving balls in your mouth
run again pick up so badly every forty
nine well you do look good thank you I
just showered reminds me that porn over
the two redheads
I will get everyone to shut up everyone
is shut up we're trying to film everyone
shut up
we made this awkward for us because you
can't read your comment no don't say
that this awkward buddy one thing
[Music]
good lunch if I'm Tyler do it yeah it's
gonna become popular just make so many
people happy
[Music]
great now we can't have this video
monetized it's only like a couple
seconds it's talking about it yes so
amazing I know I feel like I'm gonna cry
that was soon I like I like the Sally in
videos more than Sally in real life like
I love that Sally and leave it to Ryan
to ruin every good moment that's ever
happened to me
no you know I love you come come here
awkward awkward s yay you're so like
skinny and like I feel like I'm gonna
break you when I hug you because I'm so
fat so I'm just like hey you're like a
bone like a good-looking bow wait that
sounds like something else that sounds
like something else oh my god stop no
sex jokes is really this is a really
great video I know this really shows oh
the dnw
thank you so much no dude seriously that
means a lot like um
IIIi don't know why I'm having such a
hard time just putting my guard down
right now that was a really sweet video
my natural instinct is to be sarcastic
towards it I don't know what I'm doing
I'm trying to be genuine right now hold
on a second
while he's thinking about that I just
want to say yes things have been tough
for me lately but that just made
everything 10 times better so thank you
I love you Sally you're my best friend
and you mean the world to me and I've
always had faith in you and you've
always had a lot of potential and I see
you grow every time and I just think
you're a beautiful person inside and out
and that one day the best is going to
come for you I want to open my eyes that
that just happened on cam that just
happened you know that means view anyway
he needs channel you can subscribe to
the real rejects you could check out
salamandra Sally's channel a lot of fun
stuff on there a lot most of the clothes
were taken from there hold on and you
can also follow us on Facebook Instagram
and Twitter and vine and periscope a so
yah and shout out to dnw it made him cry
it made me cry you know how can you make
me cry you always look at people's lips
when they talk right I noticed that
about you
um yes yeah what do you open no mainly
it would be their teeth because I want
straight teeth so badly just like them
and I finally got it but also like I
don't know I I think lips are important